all right here to respond Herman Cain
2016 Republican presidential candidate
now Herman great to see you first bill
weld I mean that's like back to the back
to the 90s and now Joe Walsh how many
more of these pretenders will the media
glom on to to promote they will glom on
to anybody that's willing to cast
dispersions on Donald Trump I will sum
up this Joe Walsh not the one from the
Eagles the one who wants to challenge
Trump and one-word publicity the squad
AOC and all of these are the liberal I'm
sorry lunatics the more outrageous
things that they say the more likely
they are to be on TV
so when joe walsh comes along and he's
gonna challenge trump the liberals are
going yay we got somebody else that we
can put in front of the camera it's for
publicity his own self Pullip publicity
because he has seen this work for the
squad that's a gale see and others yes
the more outrageous the more outrageous
the more likely they are to get the
publicity yet herman they're the first
people to scream foul go after the you
know their livelihood if there's one
word or one phrase that they can hone in
on and some little dweeb and his
basement cuts and paste it and sends it
over there but these people say they
think they're gonna punch the president
in the face no problem right
i'm gonna burn it down we got to
basically kill off all the survivors i'm
paraphrasing what Jennifer Rubin said
make sure there are no survivors can you
imagine I mean if any of us say that
there you're destroyed you might know
work again you're not gonna burn down a
hundred and sixty four million
Republican voters okay you're simply not
but people who support Donald Trump that
lady's delusional that you showed
earlier she's absolutely delusional and
see she talks about playing nice well
Republicans are trying to play nice
they're the ones that aren't playing
nice with that kind of rhetoric and all
that rhetoric does is to ensure that
get on TV or somebody writes an article
that quotes them or Herman they get a
fancy perch at the New York Times so
they become the house conservative
they're the house conservative there's
nothing conservative about these people
they long gave up they're not the
conservative credential by the way John
Kasich who you know located he was a
good governor of Ohio but he didn't even
show up at the Republican National
Convention when he was governor of the
state when it was held in Cleveland
didn't have the grace to do that he's
now mouthing off on how he was the first
one to really doubt Trump watch I call
him out more than anybody and I have
been doing it I know you have I didn't I
didn't have like a change of heart where
we see some people say oh I used to
support him and now I don't I suspected
this from the beginning that this was
going to be disruptive to our country
and disruptive to our allies and it's
been precisely that I don't want to say
I told you so but Herman it's real
simple can we say sour grapes and
secondly all of the accusations by Joe
Walsh and others against Trump are
simply not true
period not Truman Herman it's always
great to see you come back soon thank
you